braucht dieses Land eine neue politische Kraft?
wenn man Mitte März nach Erfurt schaut,
lautet die Antwort, ja.
hier stehen menschenschlange
um mitzumachen beim Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht
1630 ist einer. 17 Uhr geht's los.
es ist das 1.
große Basis treffen der Newcomer Partei bsw.
gekommen sind etwa 500 sogenannte Unterstützer,
magisch angezogen von einer Person,
Sarah Wagenknecht,
Ex Kommunistin, Ex linke, gekonnte retorikerin,
populistin und jetzt
also auch so etwas
wie eine hoffnungsträgerin für das wahlvolk.
ich freue mich auf die neue politische Kraft
jetzt hier in Deutschland.
für manche
die hierher kommen oder viele vielleicht sogar,
ist das ne Art 1989
2 Punkt 0. ich Mein
die anderen Parteien sind Jahrzehnte etabliert.
na das muss ich natürlich entwickeln
Wagenknecht kommt heute direkt Aus der Hauptstadt,
wo es mittags im Bundestag noch um Taurus Raketen ging.
der Abend ist für die Unterstützer reserviert.
1. vorsichtiges kennenlernen
zwischen der Vorsitzenden und ihren Fans.
wir müssen halt aufpassen, Junge Parteien
laufen oft 1. Risiko auch Menschen anzuziehen,
die nicht nur konstruktiv sind.
deswegen haben wir eben das Prinzip,
mitgeht wird man eigentlich nur,
wenn wir die Menschen kennenlernen.
und wir wollen aber ja
trotzdem vielen Menschen die Möglichkeit geben
uns zu unterstützen,
die das ja auch Aus ehrlichem Herzen tun.
aber bloß keine Querdenker, rechten oder AFDler.
die Höcke
Partei könnte bei der Wahl in Thüringen 30 Prozent
erreichen. Grund genug für viele
lieber bei Wagenknecht mitzumachen.
das seh ich hier als gelungener Alternative an,
ohne dass das Wort Alternative.
im Namen steht,
weil die anderen sind einfach nur rechts.
dass manche ihrer Positionen
etwa in der migrationspolitik denen der rechten ähneln,
nimmt die Ex linke in kauf.
heute ist ihr wichtiger,
dass alle mit anpacken und zwar tatkräftig.
und wenn der europawahlkampf beginnt,
dann wird es Flyer geben,
dann wird es Plakate geben,
dann wird es Materialien geben
und da wär es natürlich ganz toll,
wenn ihr uns dabei unterstützt,
das in die postkästen zu tun,
das an die Laternen zu hängen,
weil wir werden.
sie sind ja noch eine ganz kleine Partei,
eine kleine Partei, der großes zugetraut wird.
laut Umfragen könnte sie Aus dem stand
in den Bundestag einziehen,
bei den anstehenden Landtagswahlen sogar zweistellig
abschneiden.
Berlin
hier spielt die eigentliche Musik für Wagenknecht.
selbst eine Kanzlerkandidatur kann sie sich angeblich
vorstellen.
im Bundestag hat sie ihr Büro
immer noch gleich neben den linken.
mit ihrem Ausstieg
hat sie den Ex Kollegen vergangenes Jahr den Rest
gegeben.
die Schilder sind aber noch nicht neu bei ihnen. ne ja,
ach so, ja, das stimmt.
also das dauert wahrscheinlich gut.
da stand aber auch noch 2 Jahre,
als ich nicht mehr Fraktionsvorsitzende war,
stand noch Fraktionsvorsitzende.
das scheint wirklich einen langen,
langen Vorlauf zu haben, wie das äh ausgewechselt wird.
auch sie hatte einen langen Vorlauf,
Ehe sie ihre eigene Partei gründete.
mit den alten genossen verbannt sie
am Ende nur noch innige Ablehnung.
die Trennung für sie 1. Durchbruch.
ja, das ist natürlich etwas äh, was ich Mir.
Lange gewünscht habe,
also dass man natürlich auch was äh kann dadurch.
also das war ja,
ist ja für jemand der in der Politik ist
ziemlich frustrierend,
wenn man
einfach zum Beispiel keine redezeile mehr kriegt
im Bundestag. jetzt bestimmt sie die Agenda
inklusive wöchentlichem Presse Statement im Bundestag.
heute geht es um den Tod von navalni,
Mindestlohn und natürlich das bsw.
am Rand hört reif suika zu,
einer der neuen im teamwagenknecht.
ja spannend.
ich äh bin nich so häufig im Bundestag und äh
bin jetzt im Bundespolitik
live und in Farbe
und äh
freu mich, dass ich auch im Präsidium vom bsw Ecken
mit vorbereiten kann
in welche Richtung unsere Politik
gestaltet wird.
suikard ist der Schatzmeister der Partei.
im führungszirkel gehört er zu den Polit. Neulingen.
die meisten hier waren vorher bei den linken,
haben mit Wagenknecht das Lager gewechselt.